have used the new vehicles ready to go  go crazy just thinking about these  prices I wish I was in color bling huh  crap that's that all order now before 10  Lenny will be back right after these  messages  day after day innocent buildings across  the country are disappearing  every 20 seconds the defense's property  just like this one falls victim to  explosive weapon ring  843 buildings suffered needlessly during  a recent mission and many more are in  peril  but with your donation of $49.99 you can  save a structure just like this one call  one eight five five seven two six save  and save a building and need  please hurry these helpless buildings  need you help them before it's too late